[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to another installment of
vintage Egyptologist today we are going
to be introducing a topic that I know
all of you are interested in hieroglyphs
by the end of today's video you're going
to know the origin of the term
hieroglyph how to differentiate between
hieroglyphs high Radek and demonic where
to start reading an ancient Egyptian
inscription and the three different uses
of hieroglyphs within a text so let's
begin with the most elementary aspect to
the topic today the terminology will use
now almost everyone has heard of
hieroglyphs that goes back to the
ancient Greek term
taw hero glue fika the sacred script and
by glyph it really means the sacred
carved script of the ancient Egyptians
and the ancient themselves called it
meadow nature divine words no matter
what other scripts came into the Nile
Valley the Egyptians never abandoned
hieroglyphs because it had was it just
significance no hieroglyphs as the name
implies are a sacred script a formal
script and they should be carved there
are some painted hieroglyphs as well
that are made with the nice borders the
the crisp edges internal details
individual hieroglyphs can be miniature
works of art sometimes but if you need
to write a letter to someone or need to
jot a note write a receipt the ancient
Egyptians wouldn't traditionally use
hieroglyphs for that and as some of you
may know ultimately they had two forms
of cursive script the words we use for
these go back I believe to Herodotus who
described one as what we call hieratic
for his time it was the cursive script
of priests it had been the standard
cursive that developed over time that
had been in use for millennia by the
time Herodotus is writing but in his
time it was an old-fashioned cursive so
only the priests learned it and by the
time of Herodotus really by the middle
of the first millennium BCE there's an
even more pared-down cursive that he
calls the popular script or demotic so
same route as democracy d most of the
people so we technically think of
Egyptian as having three scripts
hieroglyphic formal script erratic the
traditional cursive for a long period of
time and then demotic the cursive from
let's say very roughly middle of the
first millennium BCE to about the middle
of the first millennium CE II when the
ancient scripts in Egypt die now how are
those change over time to some extent
and hieratic the cursive changes over
time it can date things according to
these changes and the study of these
changes of the appearance of the signs
is called paleography so we'll talk a
little bit more about paleography now
there are other forms of the script that
don't get talked about quite so much
there's something that's in between
hieroglyphs and her anak what we might
call cursive hieroglyphs this is
sometimes referred to as book script
because the Book of the Dead can be
written in this hook script so media
where you are writing the inscription or
writing and ink is what really dictates
the script if you're gonna carve in
stone you will use hieroglyphs if you're
going to write a letter on papyrus you
will use high Radek but then there's
also an element of development over time
if you're writing a letter say in 200
BCE
you will be using demotic in fact we
have evidence of priests probably from
the Roman period still able to write a
pretty decent archaic form of hieratic
we see an inscription like that that
darshan published from the temples
mythos in the wedding hall east of all
cob where we work to introduce the topic
of ancient Egyptian hieroglyphs we have
to start with the three uses of a
hieroglyphic assignment the first is
phonetic
so most hieroglyphs that you see in in
ancient Egyptian texts actually
represent sounds so it might look like
an owl or a basket or a horned Viper but
what they're actually writing or the
sounds represented by those signs so I'm
going to give you one quick example that
I can do just sitting here and that is a
human hand cut off essentially at the
wrist and when you see that human hand
it is the sound D we call that a
unilateral because it represents a
single consonant there also by and tri
literals that have two or even three
consonants the second use of a
hieroglyphic sign is as an ideogram and
what this means is that the hieroglyph
is functioning both phonetically and the
meaning of the word is what that sign
actually represents so to take another
example that I can use just sitting here
is the arm the human arm cut off a
little bit above the elbow that is an
lion sound that exists in modern Arabic
and ancient Egyptian and other
afro-asiatic languages but not in
English so we normally just write it as
an A although strictly speaking that's
not what it is phonetically so the lion
arm is used as the sound lion in
multiple many many many words but if you
have that same arm and you put a
vertical stroke underneath
that means read it both phonetically as
ioan but also what the word means that
stroke says we're talking about a
physical arm and then finally the third
form of hieroglyphs a third usage we
could say is as a determinative and a
determinant it indicates the class to
which a word belongs so for example if
we're talking about a verb of motion you
use a pair of legs if you're talking
about Basenji x' Chesham dogs you would
actually have a picture of a Basenji and
there are examples that look just like
Narmer at the end of the word
and so that Basenji determinative Narmer
at the end of a hieroglyphic word
doesn't add any phonetic meaning but it
gives you a clue as to what that word
means the other really significant
aspect of determinative in ancient
agents is that hieroglyphs do not have
word brakes so when you see a line of
hieroglyphic tacks one word follows
another without a space but if you learn
to recognize the determinative it is
surprising how quickly you can pick up
on well this is a determinative so that
must be the end of a word the
predominant writing direction for the
ancient Egyptians is right-to-left
certainly for the cursive scripts that's
really the only way they wrote with very
few exceptions I've seen a couple of
graffiti where someone wrote her attic
left-to-right it doesn't look very
pretty it's not great hieroglyphs on the
other hand are exceptional they can be
written left to right right to left or
in vertical columns so they really
function as an element in the decoration
in fact the engine ship just probably
wouldn't understand our use of the term
annotation or decoration for them it's
all visual
all communication there's a verb say
Shire sesh - right but it can also mean
to draw community pain it can even mean
to to put on makeup so when you see a
hieroglyphic text and you know it can be
read either left-to-right or
right-to-left and if it's in columns
it's always from the top to the bottom
but the question is where do you start
and this is actually really easy you
always read toward the faces if John and
I were hieroglyphs in inscription let's
say war on either side of a doorway and
they love you that to make it
symmetrical you would read John from
left to right but you would read me from
right to left and sometimes they will
have an inscription that begins let's
say in the middle of a doorway and reads
in one direction on the one side and
another direction in the other and there
might be an uncle sign right in the
middle that you would read with each
text in each direction I think we should
be able to find an example oh absolutely
yes that's very common on doorways what
are so-called false doors because there
were doors for the spirit to receive
offerings like the cause spirit of the
deceased ancient Egyptian is the longest
continuous tradition of writing in world
civilizations thus far its origins go
back as far as 3000 250 BCE during the
reign of a king named scorpion and this
is a story we will tell in detail later
you probably call them self-service I
know you're the first ruler of dynasty 0
it's really about that time that we see
the proto-writing turning into true
early hieroglyphic script in the
earliest phase of the Egyptian language
we call it old Egyptian this is the
language of autobiographical tax of the
third fourth fifth and sixth dynasties
and also the Pyramid Texts which
themselves are pretty archaic by the
first time they are tested at the end
that's dynasty during the Middle Kingdom
we called the phase of the language
middle Egyptian what's really
interesting about this is that we see
middle Egyptian obviously beginning even
before the old Egyptian textual
tradition is dead and then late Egyptian
that we traditionally say really begins
to enter the written tradition around
the time of amenhotep ii through
Naughton in the middle of 18th dynasty
we actually get late Egyptian isms
showing up even as early as say the the
late old kingdom kind of early middle
Egyptian so to put this into terms that
we can kind of understand in this world
it's as if you took an abbreviation oMG
and it somehow made it into a law so was
tend to be a higher register much more
formal language where's what you're
gonna text on your phone is going to be
much more colloquial so as the Egyptian
language goes forward you have more and
more representations of the colloquial
language in writing but then there are
other genres like laws or historical
inscriptions where you really expect the
language to be formal but those two
registers can exist simultaneously it's
both chronological and it depends on the
formality of what you're saying it does
so so this is something that's usually
referred to as diglossia so in other
words in ancient Egypt if I wrote a
letter in very nice lady Gyptian during
the reign of Ramses the second about
1250 BCE that would be completely normal
wouldn't phase anyone it would be
totally acceptable expected proper but
if I wrote a letter in old Egyptian if I
tried to mimic the formulations of let's
say one of those first Intermediate
Period letters to the dad from around 20
100 BCE or so that would shock people
that would seem very strange it would be
like texting in the style of the King
James Bible and yet at the same time if
I have religious treatise and then I
have a say our quotation out of an
earlier religious text I might bring
that old register of the language in and
it would be completely proper it would
be acceptable and when you look at the
script you can have that same level of
formality versus informality you until
very late in Egyptian history would not
see high Radek carved on a temple wall
as an original that's supposed to be on
the temple in fact are there any
examples weird the first script on a
temple wall is high writing I know there
are those Dhokla steely faith begins and
I believe it begins in the first
millennium BCE that you really start to
see more formal monuments made with
hieratic as the script the monument but
already really the classic period for
this is in the Middle Kingdom already
beginning around 2,000 BCE we do start
to see the development of lapidary
hieratic this hybrid cursive
hieroglyphic script you might it's
almost like it's a it's a cursive script
that has aspects of how glyphic
orthography introduced into it so you
can write it relatively quickly you
don't have to be trained as a how
glyphic scribe but it still imparts an
aura of the formality that hieroglyphs
always bring with them one of the things
we should point out is that students
nowadays you know everyone learns
hieroglyphs first when you learn to read
and write
Egyptian but it's not what it would have
been first weekend yeah as far as we can
tell for antiquity you would first learn
cursive because that's what you would
need if you made a receipt if you wrote
a letter to someone if you signed your
name on something etc so we we have
evidence that Rock inscription sites of
the number of people who are probably
tirely literate when it comes to
day-to-day life even even writing
complex letters possibly even legal
documents etc but when they have to say
I'm going to write this in high rules
because I have some time on my hands I'm
going to try to carve this sometimes the
carving doesn't look that great because
they're a little bit uncertain as to
what hieroglyphics on or what
hieroglyphic group matches the hieratic
they want to transcribe in hieroglyphs
[Music]